I weirdly I don't know what my blood
type is I feel like I should know do you
know what your parents blood type is no
who knows wait hold up yourself
every every six months gone up does it
say it on the paper yes it's also you
have a blood condition you should
probably be able to say it on the paper
like at the top really well when they
take the blood they're not going to be
like oh yeah so he took your blood uh we
don't know what time it is though yeah
wait wait wait wait I I only saw like I
never saw a blood type yeah it has it
mine's mine says oh this is like just a
letter o yeah it's either o a b or a B
oh maybe I just didn't notice it it was
under like all the all the other A's
maybe it was like yo I scored an A in
blood man
I probably just because it's pretty
Japanese yeah and I was like oh okay oh
that's good right I got a good one no
wait is it blood type wait could you get
tested on your blood as well right yeah
yeah the quality of your blood yeah yeah
so maybe I just thought I don't know man
I mean if you're getting tested on the
quality of your blood they'll probably
tell you what your type is you're saying
it's definitely there I I'm 100 sure
there's no there's no reason for it to
not be there yeah again I just I guess I
never looked up I I just never really
noticed yeah I pretty sure yeah I mean
considering you have a blood conditioner
yeah yeah true but I mean
I get uh uh I get like a factor
injection not blood injection normally
like a factory injection it's not not
like what's that it's the stuff that I'm
missing I normally don't need a blood
injection out you don't just to stop the
blood from
like you're gonna I can temporarily have
something in my body that will will act
normal yeah so I I don't know most of
them I don't need a blood transfusion or
anything like that I just I just need
the missing component which wouldn't
they need your blood type for that no no
not for that oh really no because it's
in everyone's blood ah this is the thing
I'm missing right right so that's why I
think I never had to learn it that much
hopefully touch touch with her you never
you should probably know just in case
yeah yeah just just in case yeah I had a
medical bracelet at one point and I lost
it I just never got another one
sorry
I just hate bracelets too I just think
they're annoying right now but you wear
watches yeah but it's different and
which is nice so what's what's a medical
bracelet like just tells you like hey
where my Treasure's hidden if I die
that's the one piece yeah medical
bracelet I've not seen anyone wear one
it's like a white band right it's like a
yeah it can be why it can be anything
really it's like engraved with
information right they normally check
your engraved so it's actually like to
be like a metal thing and it could be
like saying like hey
this is what he has oh so that like he's
a [__] oh he's a sick
so he'd be like hey here's hemophilia
this type of Hemophilia so they know
right away they're like oh we gotta get
some of this stuff all right you know do
a background yeah I guess I don't know
how I don't know how [__] probably
needed in America it has your like
Insurance on there as well hopefully no
I don't know about that I think it just
says like general information that the
doctors need in case they need to
perform any kind mine just had just said
like what I had right just so I guess so
it's much quicker for them to figure out
what to do yeah and to get the stuff
they need okay okay so I did have that
but I lost it you should probably yeah
yeah actually annoying to get one she's
kind of annoying yeah but it also you
know your life's kind of depending on it
right it's fine it's like you know life
insurance kind of annoying to get I know
there's other stuff you can get like
some people have
there's other stuff
um I know there's a technology and a
comfortable was where basically it would
just like they could just it would send
everything to a phone and apparently I
can't remember this can you Google this
or something there's some kind of
Technology they have where they can
instantly see everything wow like and I
can't remember what it was like a
digital or something yeah something you
could have I don't know it might have
been a card that like an NFC chip that
Taps and then it could tell and yeah
[__] these poor [__] uh EMTs are
like you got the new uh update for this
app I can't download his life-saving
medical information say sorry about my
4GS yeah
well I don't know like I'm I guess I
guess I'm kind of like
I'm kind of not the same but like
um like I have asthma right radio comes
up but I don't know if this uh if if I
kind of just wheeled it away off it's a
normal thing it's all in your head if
it's like if it's like a normal thing
that happens as you grow older but like
I had uh I had I had asthma as a kid and
uh it was it wasn't like horrible
horrible that's what I would call it
more like mild asthma right at like the
worst but I would have to there would be
points as a kid where I would have to
like use my inhaler right whether you
know I'd been exercising or a lot of the
times it would just like randomly come
about I don't know what exactly caused
it but something caused it
um I know this is like the wrong [__]
mindset to have right but I was I I
always saw as like a [__] I always
saw as a weakness right I this which is
the wrong [__] mindset sounds very
kid way of looking at it it is it is
it's a permanent debuff yeah yeah
because having having I don't know how
to describe having asthma and just
having that hit of an inhaler yeah I was
so jealous of those kids I thought that
was sick when you got to do that yo
you're doing drugs
dude that's badass I want to try but yo
give me some of that
but like it's it's so weird because like
you you take the hit and you go from
like feeling like your chest is like
congested and like you can hardly
breathe to like having the clearest
breath of like like breath of air in
your life and I was just like you know
you know what every time yeah every time
I'm doing an asthma hit I'm admitting
defeat my lungs are stronger than this I
don't know why I thought this as a kid
but I would like it would only be like
to the Limit where right I would be like
in pure discomfort because sometimes I
I'd have like a mild kind of like asthma
thing and I would just be like nah my
lungs are stronger my lungs are built
dude I just breathe hard I'll just
literally breathe harder and it's only
like I would wait to push it to the edge
before like I could like uh barely
breathe with just [__] stupid that's
dangerous I don't recommend that I was a
dumb kid
um who was just trying to like [__]
will this asthma away but like for some
reason when I like reached teenagers uh
when I reached about like University age
I just noticed that like more and more I
just got like less asthma attacks and I
don't know what caused it
um I don't know if it's just part of
growing up or just like my stupidity
played a factor and just yeah because
reacting differently to certain
situations yeah because it's interesting
because like I didn't even know that
like asthma was a thing like that I
thought it was always just like a
permanent thing where like the moment
you develop asthma you have it for the
rest of your life I didn't know it was
like a thing that just like went away or
came back I still think I have like very
very very mild asthma I haven't had to
use it's not as bad as when you're a kid
right oh no no way no way like uh before
I would that would like I would could
not travel without my inhaler just in
case
um but I haven't needed to use mine like
I still have my inhaler in like every
travel pack that I have with me uh
whenever I go travel but I haven't had
to use it in
I think it's coming on to like a decade
well I haven't had to like use it
um so it's it's it's been it's been it's
been a long time since I've had like a
proper bad asthma attack and I don't
know I don't know what factors played
into that but I just I just look back
and I was just like why why was I so
adamant on using the [__] inhaler
like
yeah it's I guess it's kind of the same
thing as like allergies right because
like allergies are also the same because
like you know I had [__] horrible hay
fever in Australia and I always like saw
it as defeat if I like had to pull the
tissues out in the middle of the
conversation to leave boy my nose I'm
like no yeah I'll just [__] breathe
harder I just [__] do one of those I
don't need that but then I realized much
later on that like like doing the like
the hard disgusting like liquidy sniff
yeah is way more uncool than just
getting a tissue and just blowing that
[__] out yeah yeah but yeah I don't know
there's I I totally get that whole like
it's a weakness thing even though it's
not like [__] everyone it's like so
many people have asthma so many people
have hay fever it's like nothing to be
ashamed of but like yeah I don't know
what it is it's like something about you
being a kid just being like no I'm not
like the rest of them I refuse I refuse
I am a strong boy I'm gonna get through
this okay body [__] listen to me you
can fight through this you can just
breathe just stop being weak
oh God we we are the worst medical
advisors oh my God yeah hopefully uh
yeah definitely don't listen to us to
medical advice at all uh we we have
someone with a blood condition who does
not know their blood type
and asthmatic who refuses to use his
inhaler
just give me the universal blood I'll be
all right yeah the universal blood or
the universal blood what's that what's
the one there that oh negative is that
woman that works at everything or is it
a b one of them one of them you should
be the one
hey it's the doctor's job give me the
universal one the the C7 yeah give me
the best you got dogs give me a top
shelf
are you cooking or what